do you guys like to cringe I like to in
case you haven't noticed I'm kind of a
cringy guy put me in any real-life
scenario and I just won't know how to
handle it it turned into a high-five and
it just fell apart it was I never want
to do that again
but that's what makes me appreciate the
cringe even more because I understand
the cringe I bleed for the cringe so
without further ado let's go through
some of my favorite cringe special TV
edition hooray
you really scraping the barrel now Felix
I love this because it's basically how I
do all my intros hello and welcome thank
you I never felt so welcome how natural
that was it just turns around like it's
so confused the look of terror
hello guys are looking for I don't know
what it is food TV cringe it's just
funny cuz it's so it's such an organic
cringe you know what I mean when that
thing happened with Conan you know I
know you see it in my head I'm
calculating I'm like yeah I'm sure
little added that out yeah I trust the
editing system that they won't draw
attention to it they will just cut it
out no and that's why we you know it's
lime you get these beautiful moments
okay this one my boy my main reaching 30
second pitch Richard you're on
television live television you got to
give us a 30 second clip i watch this
clip to get me going in the morning to
get me started to get me boosted get a
nice big old motivational push just
watch my man Richard killing it all
right Richard chaas keys take it away
come on Richard
kill it hi you're looking for someone
who
more than just a focus on technology
you're looking for someone who has no
okay go for it tell us to speak to me
like we're saying at the dinner table go
ahead Richard what do you have what can
you offer come on Richard please
it's okay regroup for a second no
problem okay go ahead take it again and
here when all hope is lost when Frodo
lusts the rate when they Titanic sank
when that plane
no when all hope was lost Richard top 10
anime comebacks of old time kill sit he
comes back and he kills it 1000% okay
you're looking for someone who was more
than just technology savvy Dan someone
who has customer focus and international
experience a prop a person who is a
problem solver analytical yet still has
common sense yes I'm that person
he's that birds have great customer
focused skills and does great soft
skills I have facility to take
end-to-end ownership of a project and
the determination to do whatever it
takes to get the job done fantastic
Richard so glad he got through it my man
Richard it's it's not a crunch I just
love the clip you know that they're
saying in a relationship what they're
not doing in public they're doing at
home it's a bit more specific but great
saying Felix I know
well this clip is a testimony of that
and my god it's probably one of the most
painful fights I have ever seen on
television Thank You mr. president thank
you good morning everyone and welcome to
morning Joe Joe's back
is here great to have you back we did
lots of fighting over issues so it
should be a good show to know we do know
oh yeah we don't fight well we can ask
you a question everyone knows you cannot
hold hands at 6:03 okay you cannot do
any endearing gesture at 6:03 touching
hands you might as well given her a slap
on the nose we're engaged I mean we've
been engaged now for like 13 hours 603
not at 603 everyone knows that you'll be
quiet I'll hold your hand
my god but there is a chance of hail in
the morning after love eight will reach
13 - great so pick the first day of the
last month oh my god I said this and
I've said it before first of all never
kiss anyone I mean what's the point
don't kiss someone that isn't your
girlfriend fiance or wife on camera at
all just don't do it just don't do it
just don't do it okay just don't kiss
people just don't kiss anyone just don't
want to kiss for this guy it's like you
know what screw that rule you had one
job okay you know how much shape I have
to swallow for the handshake what do you
think I happen if I went into a kiss huh
what would you think would happen okay
this really is great way or is it here
yeah I'll just plain quarter o'clock
yeah his phone rings and what is he
doing
you like the uh yeah that's less awkward
couldn't he have just muted it you
didn't have to throw a chug away your
phone Jesus Christ
I love the sound but you like to enjoy
your broken phone and your lost job oh
this one is this one is great to my man
Mike craft sick he basically speaks just
like I do when it's unedited if you ever
want to know how an unedited papaya
video looks like it's basically like
this people trying to beat the heat and
trying to stay cool and to tomorrow and
people
that's it guys hope you enjoy this video
and to tomorrow don't get me wrong okay
I'm not really killing these people I am
merely celebrating it we're a group of
cranes we all know how it feels I love
this clip because whatever she's saying
it's just so goddamn boring and this
girl doing a copies in the background
just realizes that she's for the lottery
starting tomorrow open until Friday
the UAA will know can I swap my cell
phone picked up from Tuesday through
Thursday now students which everyone is
welcome to sign up live from the
newsroom Cara Minelli w UF t news she's
like what is happening beautiful cringe
where would I be without you I'm so pale
today snow is low and one of the snow
fell in Seattle in other areas this is
the kind of stuff that you know I would
if I do with this on camera Brad and
Brad - we'll just draw attention to it
so now if I ever mess up an intro you
normally I just keep going and do it
redo it but instead I have to stop the
recording and start again because of
these douchebags
these meanings
this clip is so weird okay if I no one
has to context behind this please feel
free to let me know I don't know what
the Frick her problem is I feel like
it's a broken record look at the best I
like calling you daddy thank you I can
like it what just happened what just
happened there she's just like they're
communicating
it's not about the record this morning
but honestly I feel like it was a broken
record this is like the best song I play
that song I like calling you daddy thank
you so anyway that's the best song ever
I really enjoy that you got it daddy
I like calling you daddy his reaction to
it is so wholesome it's not like weird
oh it's absolutely like calling you
daddy no no no no not a Micron's watch
okay
this clip is so painful I need a nuclear
warning on this one this is no clearly
oh my god Jesus Christ okay guys are you
ready I'm going to press play three do
we get a picture of you and then it
would be posted all around and you'll be
it'll happen in your office yeah
possibly you don't think so well it
depends you know you know I've got some
time in the camera why don't you stop by
no okay um oh Jesus Christ
what is wrong with the people you know
people talk about social issues and I'm
like that doesn't happen you watch you
watch the news and it's like right there
it's hidden in plain sight
maybe because I never had a desk job
maybe that's these you why would he say
that you know I've got some time and a
camera why don't you stop by no okay
this is in the context of I think some
naked photos and he just drops in the
weirdest tone ever
I got camera
she dropped some time in a camera why
don't you stop by yeah I'll come by
what the hell what are you where were
you thinking son as bad as the kiss to
kiss was worse that was a joke yes I
love bass clip that's right I've seen
them all I'm just showing it to you cuz
I like it okay this guy makes a weird
furry joke and no one laughs and it just
makes it so much worse okay just hang
out with my new best friend Bettina I
think you shoot you two should get a
hotel room or something a lot of action
going on over there oh it's gnarly
probably most action terrible joke why
would you and they kept going my god you
think my jokes are bed shishah sheesh ah
I need a minute I need a break
it's we got my boy I can't even watch
this this is going to do a spoken words
now write write and tell us what we're
about to hear just a priest there it's
just a freak you know every style I
notice a Comic Sans there by the way
okay
years ago they tried it years ago they
try this just put me in it check it
check it
come on Dave freestyle try to read
something from your book yeah uh I was
wondering like surely Mo's rappers have
some sort of hey give us a freestyle
they just have like a go-to rhyme right
maybe they're writing some song or
something some material that's what I
would do if I had a rapper because I'm a
but cuz I don't want to end up like Mike
here that's right everybody I make an
effort to not appear cringy here's like
actual customer out here what's what's
the best kind of firework to buy
wouldn't you like to know whether boy
get sketchy
back to you that kid has been raised on
a pure onion diet I can tell this is
onion versus soy demonstrated right here
wouldn't you like to know whether boy
asserting his dominance straight away
delivered that line like a pull intent
like that that kid made him remember his
days in elementary school so humiliating
this is a new day this is too big so
basically they they came to rescue this
hiker because they left a message in the
sand and you know a call for help by
stones you know the classic mean send
help with so here's a live footage of it
you're making something please send
something please thank god she's okay
probably someone did in fact send her
news what an absolute hero we sent our
team out to send her nudes and it worked
out great everyone was just happy it
cured the heat it just fixed all
problems
[Music]
I'm gonna look at the forecast while
they sing let's go ahead we got our
phase right before make it our phase now
before workout that's why they sing all
right that's it for me for now lemon
leave a like if you cringed leave a like
if you check out a another video I hit
the battle button and right I know
you're gonna keep this just don't just
cut it out there